und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend die panzerdebatte schlägt
politisch weiter hohe Wellen im Innen-
und Ausland so haben die baltischen
Staaten heute einen gemeinsamen Appell
an Deutschland gerichtet und in der
Berliner Ampelkoalition gibt es über die
Blockadehaltung des Kanzlers offenen
Streit das reicht von Enttäuschung bei
den Grünen bis hin zu unverhohlener Wut
wie Sie
fdp-verteidigungspolitikerin Marie Agnes
strak Zimmermann gestern hier im heute
journal sagte worüber sich wiederum
SPD-Fraktionschef Rolf Münze nicht
ärgerte der ihn und vorwirft sie und
andere redeten Deutschland in eine
militärische Auseinandersetzung hinein
für die die seit fast einem Jahr mitten
in diesem Krieg sind sind solche
Debatten weit weg vom täglichen
Überlebenskampf und der Trauer um ihre
Toten Kathrin Altendorf berichtet aus
der Ukraine
die Häuser im Zentrum von borodianca
einer Kleinstadt in der Nähe von Kiew
sind zu traurigen Symbolen der
Zerstörung geworden verloren und
bewohnbar inmitten der Trümmer füttert
die zehnjährige Veronika die Katzen die
zurückgeblieben sind sie selbst hat ihr
zu Hause verloren und lebt mit den
Eltern in einer Notunterkunft von hier
unten aus kann sie ihr Kinderzimmer im
obersten Stockwerk erkennen
mein Vater sagt am Ende des Sommers
sollte der Krieg zu Ende sein dann
werden sie die Krim befreien wir alle
hoffen darauf dass der Krieg bald zu
Ende ist am 24 Februar dauert der schon
ein Jahr
im Supermarkt der zentral neuer Straße
sind Taschenlampen und Kerzen besonders
begehrt denn in vielen Häusern fällt
immer wieder Strom und Heizung aus und
gerade heute ist es besonders kalt am
Tiefpunkt so sehen viele Menschen in
borodianca ihr Land nach elf Monaten
Krieg fast jeder hier hat Brüder Väter
oder Ehemänner an der Front was denken
Sie hier über Deutschlands zögern
Leopard Panzer zu liefern
ich habe keinen Grund Ihnen einen
Vorwurf zu machen sie werden ihre Gründe
dafür haben ich denke sie werden jetzt
alles abwägen und dann werden sie uns
sie doch geben und uns helfen
jetzt hilft uns die ganze Welt Amerika
Deutschland und wir sind dafür sehr
dankbar wir brauchen diese Hilfe weil
wir nichts haben mit was sollen unsere
Jungs kämpfen in das Lob sie durch
das die Ukraine auf die Unterstützung
des Westens bauen kann darauf vertrauen
die meisten Menschen hier in borodianca
allen Enttäuschungen und Rückschlägen
zum Trotz
zu den vielen schrecklichen Folgen
dieses Krieges gehört dass er den Hunger
auf der Welt verschärft die Ukraine kann
nicht mehr so viel Getreide produzieren
und exportieren wie in früheren Zeiten
als sie gerade für afrikanische Länder
ein wichtiger Lieferant war hinzu kommt
der Klimawandel der ärmere Länder längst
mit voller Wucht trifft während Benzin
berichtet
sie beten für ihr totes Kind gestorben
an Hunger in Somalia herrscht momentan
die schlimmste Dürre seit Jahrzehnten
kaum Regen und das seit fünf Jahren das
Land mitten in der Hungerkatastrophe
es ist erschütternd wir können nicht
schnell genug helfen haben einfach nicht
genügend Mittel wir haben nur die Hälfte
von dem was wir wollen
bis zum Jahr 2030 will die
Weltgemeinschaft den Hunger besiegen
aktuell aber wird es nicht besser
sondern stetig schlimmer zeigt der
Welthunger-Index
die Karl der Hungernden steigt stetig an
seit 20 15 momentan hungern ungefähr 828
Millionen Menschen das bedeutet diesen
Menschen ist es Menschenrecht auf
Nahrung per Wert
in dieser Lage lädt der deutsche
Landwirtschaftsminister zum weltweit
größten Treffen mit seinen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der neue Konsens einfach
Hilfsgüter liefern reichen nicht der
globale Norden müsse gerade in Afrika
mit aufbauen Deutschland und die
Europäische Union müssen endlich
präsenter sein wir dürfen das fällt
nicht den autoritären Staaten überlassen
die dort aktiv sind und durch ihre
Investition versuchen neue
Abhängigkeiten zu schaffen erste mir
meint auch China das nicht an der
Konferenz teilnimmt Russland wurde gar
nicht eingeladen der Präsident der
Ukraine wendet sich per Videobotschaft
an die Agrarminister sein Land war mal
die Kornkammer Europas der Krieg habe
die Exporte jetzt
kopiert der must es muss wieder Weizen
auf fruchtbarem Boden geben keine Krater
von Explosionen
in Zeiten vieler Krisen bis 2030 den
Hunger besiegen dafür bleiben noch 8
ernten
zeitgleich zur Agrarministerkonferenz
findet in Berlin die agrar- und
Ernährungsmesse Grüne Woche statt damit
geht es jetzt bei dir weiter Hanna ja
denn die Namen mehrere tausend Menschen
zum Anlass um für eine nachhaltigere und
sozialere Landwirtschaft auf die Straße
zu gehen mit rund 50 Traktoren zogen die
Protestierenden durch das Berliner
Regierungsviertel und forderten unter
anderem faire Erzeugerpreise und weniger
Lebensmittelverschwendung dazu
aufgerufen hatten zahlreiche
Organisationen darunter Bauern und
Umweltschutzverbände
nach Israel dort haben sich in Tel Aviv
laut Polizeiangaben rund hunderttausend
Menschen versammelt um gegen die
Regierung von Präsidenten Netanjahu zu
protestieren vor allem gegen die
geplante Justizreform diese sieht vor
dass das Parlament künftig mit absoluter
Mehrheit Urteile des höchsten Gerichts
über stimmen kann es ist der dritte
Samstag in Folge an dem es zu massiven
Protesten in Israel kommt
und auch in Peru gab es heute wieder
Demonstrationen gegen die Regierung bei
denen es erneut zu schweren
Auseinandersetzungen gekommen ist in der
Hauptstadt Lima warfen protestierende
Steine auf die Sicherheitskräfte die
Polizei setzte Tränengas ein seit Wochen
kommt es in Peru zu Unruhen bei denen
mittlerweile dutzende Menschen getötet
wurden die Demonstrierenden fordern
unter anderem sofortige Neuwahlen und
die Freilassung des inhaftierten
Ex-Präsidenten Castillo
die Chinesen erleben gerade was für uns
schon längst die da möglich ist
uneingeschränkt zu reisen Familienfeiern
Partys und Großveranstaltungen
abzuhalten in China beginnt das
Neujahrsfest das halbe Land ist
unterwegs nachdem das drei Jahre lang
weitgehend verboten war allerdings gibt
es einen Unterschied zu unseren ersten
corona-lockerungen im Sommer 2020 waren
die Inzidenzen bei uns niedrig und als
nach dem zweiten Winter Lockdown im Mai
2021 ein Großteil der Maßnahmen wieder
aufgehoben wurde waren unter den älteren
bereits viele geimpft die Verhältnisse
in China sind gänzlich andere Elisabeth
Schmidt und Miriam Steiner berichten
das neue Jahr des Hasen soll für
Harmonie und Konfliktlösung stehen auch
in diesem kleinen Dorf in an Heu im
Osten Chinas hoffen sie dass die
viruswelle endlich aufhört
Frau Tschang ist wann der Arbeiterin und
konnte die gut 1000 Kilometer aus Peking
endlich wieder in die Heimat reisen in
den vergangenen Jahren war das schwierig
egal wo man hinfahren wollte man
brauchte immer einen grünen
gesundheits-code-regeln wurden streng
überwacht
das ist halt China da leben viele
Menschen und da waren solche Maßnahmen
wohl nötig
jetzt gibt es diese Regeln nicht mehr
jetzt reist das Virus wohl ungebremst
von den Städten aufs Land mehr als zwei
Milliarden zu Bus und Flugtickets wurden
nach offiziellen Angaben gebucht nach
dem Neujahrsfest befürchten
internationale Experten könnte die Zahl
der Kobe Toten noch mal deutlich steigen
auf bis zu 36.000 pro Tag wir wissen
dass schwere corona-verläufe
letztendlich
intensivmedizinisch versorgt werden
müssen das steht auf dem Land überhaupt
nicht zur Verfügung wir werden fürchte
ich ja sehr viele Todesfälle einfach zu
Hause erleben
Chinas Staatsführung geht nicht davon
aus dass die Feiertage zu einem
superspreading Event werden knapp eine
Milliarde Chinesinnen und Chinesen
hätten sich bereits mit kovit angesteckt
Mediziner treibt aber noch eine ganz
andere Sorge um die schwere Zahl von
Infektionen in China sind einfach ein
Problem und können dazu führen dass neue
Varianten entstehen
neujahrskala im Staatsfernsehen alles
wie vor der Pandemie keiner im Publikum
muss mehr Maske tragen doch während
hunderte Millionen das Jahr des Hasen
feiern verbreitet sich das Virus weiter
durchs Land
[Musik]
und jetzt die Lottozahlen an diesem
Samstag die lauten vier 19 24 43 44 45
Superzahl 7 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
die Wetteraussichten morgen schneit es
leicht mit abnehmender Tendenz nur in
Ostbayern verstärkt sich der Schneefall
am Nachmittag minus drei bis plus 4 Grad
die neue Woche beginnt ruhig Sonne und
Wolken wechseln sich ab am Mittwoch ganz
im Norden etwas Regen und es wird ein
wenig milder
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
der zweiten Halbzeit viel Spaß dabei bis
morgen auf Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]